du cannabis à usage thérapeutique dans
une tribune du parisien médecins et
associations militent pour une
expérimentation dès janvier 2021
en france le débat est ancien déjà en
1982 le cannabis à usage médical était
évoquée pour soulager les patients
atteints de maladies lourdes pour se
servirait de dérives et modifié à partir
des principes actifs du cannabis pour
empêcher les vomissements induits par la
chimiothérapie que l'on donne aux
cancéreux c'est une parole rare dans le
milieu médical français surtout à cette
période pour que le cannabis
thérapeutique soit à nouveau abordée il
faut attendre 1996 cette année là la
californie devient le premier état
américain le légaliser
à san francisco de nombreux malades du
sida y avaient recours de manière
illicite
quand j'utilise la marijuana ça m'aide
ça soulage la douleur ça m'évite de
prendre deux comprimés comme de la
mangue frimousses des dérivés de
morphine et en plus ça stimule mon
appétit en france le cannabis est classé
comme drogue depuis 1970 ce point même
titre que la cocaïne ou l'héroïne hors
de question de suivre l'initiative
californienne malgré les demandes
répétées de patients chiche souffre
comminges américain donc dans l'or dans
la même situation je devrais pouvoir
bénéficier des mêmes possibilités dans
les années 2000
le débat continue je les malades la
classe politique mais aussi la
communauté scientifique le cannabis
thérapeutique divise depuis des années
il ya une confusion des genres entre le
traitement de la douleur avec des
médicaments dits stupéfiants et
l'utilisation de molécules stupéfiante
dans le cadre de la toxicomanie
certains fut malgré tout dans
l'illégalité en 2002 un séropositif est
condamné pour avoir cultivé son propre
cannabis
résultat dix mois de sursis et cinq ans
de mise à l'épreuve pour détention de
stupéfiants
je vais vraiment une injonction
thérapeutique où on sera suivie comme
comme comme les personnes qui va mourir
qu'on leur donne de la morphine et sont
pas accusés eux d'être de toxicomanie un
cadre médical et légal pour
l'utilisation du cannabis thérapeutique
non pas à fumer qui dans des médicaments
des politiques de gauche comme de droite
ne sont pas opposés à l'image du député
ump richard dell'agnola en 2003 il faut
a priori rien réfuté il n'y rien récuser
si certains pays ils sont avancées
faisons aussi des études
regardons les choses s'il est avéré que
le cannabis peut dans certaines maladies
lourdes graves pathologies améliorer les
traitements et peut-être soulager la
douleur pourquoi pas en france
le cannabis thérapeutique est toujours
interdit en europe
il est légal sur prescription médicale
dans certains pays à l'image du portugal
de l'allemagne ou encore de la norvège
[Musique]